voici le début d'un voyage intérieur
pour victor pilon qui reprend sa façon
le mythe de sisyphe en déplaçant du
sable sept heures par jour six jours par
semaine et pendant un mois sisyphe
représente aussi le passage du temps
l'éternel recommencement
dans la mythologie grecque 6f est un
homme qui a défié les dieux il a donc
été condamné à faire un travail absurde
poussé une pierre jusqu'en haut d'une
colline sans jamais y parvenir car cette
pierre va redescendre malgré tous ses
efforts 6 f est obligé de vivre le
moment présent je vais réfléchir je vais
penser aux gens que j'aime à aux amis
aux gens que j'ai perdu parce que
clairement mon conjoint
qui était décédé que cette lettre un peu
un ultime hommage à sylvain le mythe de
sisyphe a profondément marqué les
intellectuels du xxème siècle à cause de
l'essai du même nom de l'écrivain albert
camus face à l'absurdité et face à la
mort camus avait pour seule réponse la
révolte et le combat d'arkham et nous
dit qu'il faut vie maintenant d'un
moment présent il faut pas vie pour un
high art pour lui pour autre chose que
la vie très sain
tout comme albert camus le conjoint de
victor pilon est décédé dans un accident
de voiture corey décisive de tout cela
albert camus le dit si bien qu'on doit
l'imaginé heureux
cgpi qui devient finalement ce n'est
plus un chantier il accepte son sort ce
que j'ai une fois qu'on accepte l'action
dit et on compose avec et on essaie des
créatifs et vers le public pourra
assister gratuitement à cette
performance marathon qui a lieu au stade
olympique un lieu symbolique à la limite
ce bâtiment là quand qui est dénigré on
compte tous les québécois que les
québécois ce qu'on investit on a refait
une beauté à la tour au centre sportif
donc il ya un effort constant même si on
irait mais pourquoi qu'on jette pas les
gants bien et non le bâtiment et nous
dépasse et monumental est colossal nous
sommes tous en quelque part décisive et
victor pilon nous démontre qu'à travers
nos souffrances il y à de la lumière ici
louis philippe ouimet radio-canada m'ont
rien
[Musique]